لكن هل انتهى الامر عند هذا الحد
بالتاكيد الى ربما لن ينتهي قريبا فماسك
الذي تعاهد باستعاده ثقه الجمهور بتويتر
ما ظن في الكشف عن المزيد من الملفات
الحساسه ومفاجاه اخرى على مستوى اعلى
واخطر الجزء الرابع من الملفات كشف عما
وصف بتعاون بين مسؤوليه تويتر
والديمقراطيين والوكالات الفيدراليه لعزل
الرئيس السابق
هل هذا يعني تمت علاقات وثيقه لمسؤوليه
تويتر مع الوكالات الفيدراليه هذا ما
تقوله الوسائط بل وتشير الى اجتماعات
اسبوعيه مع مكتب التحقيقات التي زهره
الامن الداخلي والاستخبارات الوطنيه
لم تكن من داخل شركه فحسبوا انما من
خارجها ميشيل اوباما نعم زوجته الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما اذ جاء حظر
وترامب من تويتر بعد يوم من مطالباتها
بازالته نهائيا لكن اين رئيس التنفيذي
السابق لشركه تويتر جاك دور سي من كل هذه
التسريبات
ظهر واعترف بالاخطاء في ادارهته
لقد حان الوقت الان لشركات وديع السيليكون
التوقف عن تمكين هذا السلوك الوحشي وحظي
هذا الرجل بشكل دائم هذا ما قالته ميشال
اوباما في رساله واجهتها الى مسؤوليه
تويتر كشافه النقاب عنها الجزء الرابع من
التسريبات التي نشرها مالك التويتر الجديد
داخل المنصه لاشهر في السابع من يناير عام
وواحد 2020 وادت لحضر حساب الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب
اظهرت الملفات وايضا ان تويتر حافظ على
سيادتك تسمى استثناءات من اجل المصلحه
العامه حين لم يتم حظر المسؤولين
المنتخبين حتى لو بدا انها تنتهي سياسات
اخرى في حين تم رفعوا تعليقه ترامب المؤقت
لانه تم تجاهل هذه السياسه على وجه
التحديد